and so we begin this NewsHour in Sudan
where the death toll has now reached 459
people killed during 11 days of conflict
sporadic gunfire has been heard in some
areas of Khartoum and that is despite a
new ceasefire brokered by the United
States and Regional powers on Monday
several previous ceasefires between
Sudan's Army and the rapid support
Forces paramilitary Group have failed to
hold and in the past few minutes the
World Health Organization has warned of
a high risk of biological Hazard after a
laboratory was seized let's go live to
Hibba Morgan in cartoon Hiba what more
can you tell us this morning
well there's been a lot of concerns
about biological hazards here in the
capital Horizon even before this
laboratory was seized uh by an armed
group it's not clear which armed group
yet has ceased or where exactly it's
located but some of the Medics who we
spoke to say that it could be located in
the hearts of hortum that's where most
intense fighting between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army
have been taking place but the doctors
who spoke to say that there are other
biological concerns as well the fact
that there are dead bodies that have
been piling up on the streets and in
hospitals in closed spaces for days now
without proper burial burial and high
temperatures so that's also causing
concerns and it's not clear again which
side is taking over this National
Laboratory here in hartum but fighting
has been ongoing between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army in
various districts around the capital in
the Northern parts of the capital people
say they were able to hear artillery
strikes and they can see the fight to
Jets overhead as well as in the Twin
City of umdurman people said that they
were able to here artillery strikes and
that they had to stay inside their homes
because they were worried that this
ceasefire will not hold again I was
going to ask you about the status of the
ceasefire and whether it could best be
described as holding as completely
broken or tentative
well it depends on the residential area
that you're in people in the Southern
and Eastern parts of Horton have
witnessed intense fighting over the past
few days but they say that today is
relatively quiet in the northern part of
the capital along the Nile Bank people
say they were able to hear artillery
strikes and they could see the fighter
jets but when you go further north
people say that it's been quieter one of
the residents who we spoke to just a few
minutes ago say this is the quietest day
since the fighting started 11 days ago
and it's giving him the chance to
consider evacuating his family in the
northern in the southern parts are in
the
I'm not sure if you can hear that but
yeah that partly answers our question
we can hear
it does indeed we do we do hear have
heavy artillery and gunfire being
exchanged between the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army so it looks
like the ceasefire is not holding
everywhere around the capital Khartoum
all right we have our answer huben
Morgan reporting from the capitol thank
you very much
more people have been fleeing and some
governments are continuing with
evacuations with cartoons International
Airport closed foreign governments are
looking elsewhere to get their citizens
out the dongola local airport is one
option that's in the northern part of
the country closer to Egypt to the West
there's also the Shahid sabera airport
that's located in Sudan's Darfur region
another possible evacuation route is
through the port Sudan International
Airport that's in the Red Sea Province
and a relatively short distance from the
Saudi Port City of Jeddah some roads
that remain open can get people closer
to Ethiopia Egypt and South Sudan land
Crossings with those countries have
remained open so far a lot of countries
are looking to Djibouti also as a
logistical Hub the U.S deployed forces
there before launching evacuations from
Sudan Japan and South Korea have sent
Medical Teams there as a precaution the
U.S France Italy the UK and Saudi Arabia
were among the first countries to carry
out evacuations and that list is growing
as the violence spreads across parts of
Sudan
now the U.N has said it is bracing for
up to 270 000 people to flee uh Sudan
into Chad and South Sudan Faith casino
is the regional spokesperson at the
unhcr she joins us from Nairobi give us
a sense of the numbers that we're seeing
arrive in both those countries right now
thank you so much um
from Sudan apparently are into South
Sudan and Chad
um I'll start with South Sudan where we
have seen uh nearly 4 000 South Sudanese
refugees
who are in Sudan returning to South
Sudan and they're mainly coming in
through border crossing points in Upper
in the upper Nile State we're also
seeing up to 20 000 people who've
arrived recently in chat
um along the border with um
and so you know we continue to monitor
the situation in the different
neighboring countries we don't yet have
reports of arrivals in other neighboring
countries we do know that there has we
do have reports of people
um you know movement into Egypt but we
are working with authorities there as
well just to verify
um the kind of movements that are going
in and how many people are arriving what
happens to the people who make it across
one of those borders right either in
Chad or inside South Sudan what happens
to them once they get there
so unhcr teams are currently present in
the Border
border chart in South Sudan
registrations registration centers where
some of these arrivals can be registered
um I should clarify and I should mention
that in South Sudan Visa South sudanism
certainly refugees who are returning to
South Sudan these are people who you
know have been able to make their way
into the country and so uh support apart
from giving relief items at the border
is also to see how we can support them
to move onwards to their areas you know
to their home areas in chat we also have
response teams
um on the ground along the border you
know working with governments and
partners to ensure that we're able to
provide humanitarian response um at core
really high chance as people would need
what does that response look like so are
they going to be living in tents do they
have places to go are these people who
tend to have relatives in those
countries
so in the case of South Sudan as I said
these are people who fled something and
are now coming back and we're seeing
more people you know opting to go back
to their areas
um of origin or to their home areas and
we're still working with governments to
ascertain exactly
um where people you know will be
Sheltering but we are at the border
points you know trying to really work
through this complex and complicated
situation to ensure that they do not
shelter in Chad we know we are working
again with governments and partners to
ensure that they have sufficient shelter
um you know moving them away from border
points where they're arriving is about
five kilometers
um away and so we we're working with
government and partners to ensure that
they can be moved to safer areas either
within
um existing
um sort of refugee camps and local
communities around the areas that
they're arriving and one thing perhaps
we should point out for our viewers is
usually the first people who can leave a
risky situation like what we're seeing
in Sudan
they're actually those who have the
means to leave and who are relatively
speaking better off
sorry I'm losing you I can't really
really question
now I was making the point that usually
the people who managed to leave risky
areas first are usually the people who
have the means to do it and are
relatively better off is that what
you're observing
I mean we're observing people who are
able to flee arriving in these countries
um that I've just mentioned and we're
also seeing that we have to you know
sort of walk around
um
um the the resources that we have in
these different countries uh to receive
um the new arrivals bear in mind that
these countries that are receiving the
new arrivals already have existing large
populations of refugees and internally
displaced people so they say oh you know
they have challenges of their own in
terms of
um responding to ref uh to displacement
situations in their country so I'm not
sure I answered the question correctly I
didn't quite hear the answer the
question but this is what I can say in
terms of abilities to respond absolutely
Faith Casino thank you for sharing all
that information with us thank you
is in Khartoum where people are trying
to escape the violence
we are now on the street and this is one
of the many buses heading towards Port
Sudan there are a number of families on
board who want to get out of Hartung
there are also a number of foreigners
including Turks and Egyptians we will
now go and speak to some of them to find
out about their conditions and
circumstances and how they managed to
get out
it's not safe for the buses to reach
people's neighborhoods and especially at
night it's not safe because of the
ongoing exchange of gunfire the only
time it's safe is in the morning
through this interview with Al Jazeera
I'd like to reassure my family in Saudi
Arabia mom dad and sisters that I am
well and safe and soon very soon if
God's willing I will reunite with my
whole family
foreign there are fears among the people
that the situation may deteriorate
because of lack of services and basic
needs such as water and food all these
things have prompted people in Khartoum
to leave the city and search for a safer
place and to leave the country
this bus is for people who have money to
get transported outside there are others
who don't have enough money to leave
this area
the bank application doesn't have any
cash the application is not even working
I don't understand why people are taking
advantage of this situation people must
stand together help each other so the
people can get out of this situation
there's fear among the people of
Khartoum that after the evacuation of
foreign Nationals the city might become
a war zone that's why we see many people
leaving however there are those who
don't have enough money to leave
Khartoum